tokio pasó el testigo a parís la ciudad
que acogerá en 2024 las justas de verano
anida algo la alcaldesa de parís recibió
la bandera olímpica de manos de tomás
para el presidente del comité olímpico
internacional esto fue durante la
ceremonia de clausura que se llevó a
cabo aquí en el estadio olímpico de
toque una ceremonia sobria pero muy
emotiva en la que predominó la música y
la cultura japonés en todo caso parís
hizo la presentación de sus juegos con
un vídeo mostrando los lugares más
emblemáticos de la capital la francesa y
empezando con una marsellesa en tonada
desde el el techo del estadio de francia
y terminando con el saxofón de toma
pesqué a bordo de la estación espacial
internacional en todo caso estos juegos
desde tokio 2020 que debían marcar una
antes y un después pero lo hicieron no
por las razones que se esperaba porque
tuvieron que hacerse un año después de
lo programado en medio de esta pandemia
de coronavirus y sobre todo esta
pandemia que tuvo en vilo la realización
de estos juegos hasta el último momento
sin embargo para decirse que de hecho si
fue un éxito porque fue un éxito para
los atletas hubo récords mundiales
récords olímpicos que se batieron y
muchos deportistas esperaron más de un
año y se tuvieron que preparar bajo
condiciones complicadas en medio del coi
de 19 para poder participar aquí se
vieron historias muy bonitas de
deportistas que además pues dicen
también adiós al deporte terminaron sus
carreras aquí como por ejemplo paula
pareto la judoca argentina o mijaín
lópez quien se colgó una cuarta medalla
de oro en lucha greco-romana así se
despidió el o cubano de estas justas de
verano todo caso ahora queda el trabajo
para parís a 2000 a 24 que quiere
realizar los juegos olímpicos comillas
más económicos de la historia un
presupuesto de tan sólo tres mil 900
millones de euros
eso es cinco veces menos que lo que
costaron los juegos de tokio 2020